-Gigi Hadid, I love you so much.
Welcome.
-Hi, Jimmy. Love you.
-Thank you so much
for doing our show,
and I got to say congratulations
on expecting a baby.
It's just the best news ever.
-Thank you so much.
Obviously, we wish we could've
announced it on our own terms,
but we're very excited and happy
and grateful for everyone's
well wishes and support.
So, thanks.
-It's the best news
that you could ever have
in the entire world,
even in this crazy world
where any news is
kind of good news.
Your news was great news.
-Yeah, definitely non-bad news,
and we're super happy now.
-It was a ray of sunshine
that we all needed.
And, so, I'm so happy.
And I will tell you this.
Tons of people will give you
advice and stuff like that,
and they're like,
"Oh, they grow up so fast.
Enjoy it."
And I don't want to be
that person
because they are kind of right.
But don't over do it, but just
be present for every part of it.
-Yeah. No, I'm trying, like,
especially during this time.
It's a nice silver lining
to be able to, like, be home
and together and really
experience it day by day.
-Congrats to Zayn, too,
and tell him
that if you guys need anything,
call Uncle Jimmy.
I'll make sure you guys
are taken care of.
-Oh, best Uncle Jimmy.
-Happy birthday, by the way.
That was last week.
-Yeah, 25. It was good.
I saw some Instagram photos
of you, and it looked like fun.
Was it a giant bagel involved
or something?
-Yeah, so we did, like,
a breakfast party of, like,
a few people and then a dinner
party with the same few people.
So, we tried to, like,
make it a day, but, yeah,
in the morning,
my family brought out
a everything bagel cake,
which already blew my mind
because my craving has been
everything bagels.
I eat a everything bagel a day,
and, so, I was already, like,
so excited that my birthday cake
was a everything bagel.
-Yeah, that's awesome.
-But then I found out
that Buddy,
the Cake Boss, made my cake.
-Wait! That was a cake?!
-Yes! Yes!
-I thought it was a giant bagel!
No, it was actually the cake.
It was marble cake
with chocolate buttercream
and then chocolate-chip
buttercream inside.
It was my favorite.
-"Cake Boss." He's a genius.
-"Cake Boss."
Like, I can do the whole,
like, [ As Buddy ]
"Welcome to Carlo's Bakery.
Every month,
thousands of cakes and pastries
goes out these doors."
-[ Laughing ]
-"This is the crew,
mia famiglia.
We're gonna take this bakery
to the top.
They call me Buddy.
I'm the boss."
[ Normal voice ]
Like, I will binge that.
I love him.
And I don't know if it was,
like, my hormones right now
or, like, just, like,
quarantine emotional-ness.
Like, I cried every five minutes
for, like, an hour.
Every time I thought about
that Buddy made my cake,
I couldn't stop crying.
-Bagel cake made you cry.
-Of happiness.
I was just so, like,
honored that he would, like,
make me a cake
during quarantine.
-That's super cool.